mais toujours propre oui mais vraiment
tout le monde est donc sur le terrain
ils sont tous très gai là si l'on la
boue et thoune il est passé normal il
fait pas exprès l'imaginent denis
brogniart mais l'arrivée les
travailleurs des tâches d'harissa ici
pour la suite
bon les gars mais ils sont tous pop les
annales la wii le maillot lui un ouais
mais reçoit on rappelle qu'à ces deux
animateurs de m6 à calais contente alors
la loire paca fait partie du groupe rtl
oui nadja aussi un bon bah je viens des
jolies femmes tu as un long couteau tu
fais une fine lame
vous êtes en vacances et tailler dans le
vif tous tes frères aubière
qu'aujourd'hui tu as dans le pif mais
moi que mon cadeau te plaise août à
supporter c'est avec tout mon coeur que
là je te la porte
isabelle morini bosc est ce qu'elle est
prête
isabelle et dans la cour isabelle c'est
très simple il y à sept cordes dans la
cour avec des ballons reliés à ses
cordes
un bizuth elle va re elle va tirer à
chaque fois des corps ainsi elle tombe
sur les paillettes
vous aurez trois chances
isabelle vous fait partir en vacances
arrêtez vous si l'ossature a pas mettez
vous bien de 20 ans bien derrière la
corniche à la terre ou bien à l'accord
ne vous inquiétez pas bien à l'accord si
c'est des planètes j'ai gagné allez-y
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement non
pourquoi dans une menace j'adore les
aigles ouais les voir planer les voir
rentrer aux nuits et voir les serres en
avant mais que tu vas leur dire tu
parlais glock
je parle corbeau asie palois mais vous
jure que c'est vrai a dit palois et
quand je fais ça les corbeaux
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l'amarok est là on a mis ça que ça je
pense que tu encore su bien tu dois y
est la prod les mecs on est en train de
perdre isabelle morini bosc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
cette série ça tu vas tu as mangé un peu
je prenais la dans vos bras allez-y
j'temmerde jean-michel sur les voies
concentrez vous demain vous avez une
émission extrêmement important c'est
important vous vous allez vous allez
marmonné j'ai l'impression d'être avec
des ouf quand il ya une meuf ces
messieurs toujours comme un but et
maintenant ça comme un succès sa maman
très bien aller mais je connais la mèche
et bien les courants sa danse auriez
vous aimé quoi ça m'aide et me daquo pas
trop je sais pas on dit nous un peu
comme ça vous va comme ça je peux bien
coller c'est quoi